each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
before I start thanks for all sitting
sitting through everything I mean this
is the last talk of the day as many
people have said and as you heard time
and time again the era of remote sensing
cheap ground-based sensors and web
service accesses is here there's a data
deluge it's a data earthquake it's a
data tsunami it's a data flood but very
often turning that data into science
requires extra information we've started
talking about as ancillary data you've
got to actually curate that ancillary
data along with the other data in order
to actually get the science out so this
talk this afternoon is with my colleague
Deb agrawal at the Lawrence Berkeley
Laboratory talking about our experience
with the flux net community flexnet it's
a network of networks we were very
fortunate to get kind of by chance
connected with them it's 467 towers you
can see across the United States most of
them are actually in the Americs
collaboration in the United States or in
a carbo Europe collaboration in Europe
however there's vana two in the Pacific
as well as Coco flux oz flux and many
other collaborators 967 site years from
253 towers these towers are various
different shapes ranging from the 397
meter tower in Minnesota to smaller
installations of sensors and croplands
each towered is measuring about 20
different measurements raw measurements
solar radiation precipitation
temperature and 20 derived variables the
science is really all about
understanding the interactions between
micro meteorology and plants one of the
scientists we work with calls it the
earth breathing in addition there are
145 ancillary variable so one of the
things I want you to do is 40 145 4145
this total data is about 800 million
numbers right now it's half hourly data
cut down from 10 Hertz data but it self
for the original data set was assembling
process in early 2007 the previous data
set was about 20 times smaller this is
also a living data set we're expecting a
data release data upset the update upset
that's good and we have 75 paper teams
with over 200 scientists so it's it's
actually one of the larger environmental
collaborations what's environmental
sensor data well you all know this right
it's time series data over some period
of time at some location you may
actually end up with raw data the actual
voltages that you have to then compute
into a science variable like like soil
temperature you may be getting a more
processed data in elf or like we deal
with is gap fill quality assess it's
about as good as it gets one thing it's
absolutely true with environmental data
is recalibrations gaps and errors our
way of life it's not like putting a
sensor in the data center okay one of
the best pieces of mail I've ever read
on the on the reflector was the mail
about vultures okay birds may poop but
vultures chew okay today environmental
sensor data is somewhere in the
gigabytes two terabytes depending on
where you are in the processing that
another thing to notice of course is
time is not another access environmental
remote sensing data a much much emerging
happening here we've been working the
summer as you heard early this morning
with with guy on the modis satellite
that's an example of motifs are
reprojection showing a surface
temperature the black spots there are
clouds one of the things we see
happening is making virtual sensors our
colleagues at Oak Ridge generate virtual
sensors out of the motifs data by simply
picking you the right pixel let's
environmental ancillary data well it's
pretty much everything else okay one of
the common things I show on this slide
is a garbage pail because
that's often what it is these three
slides are from webcams that's phonology
data showing you the V early spring mid
spring green up phonology you get fires
sediment leaf area at work tree rings
it's it's a grab bag okay a couple of
learnings observations along the way we
thought latitude and longitude we're
constants for a site silly us what were
we thinking sometimes sites move a
little bit sometimes because of typos
and other things you just don't get it
right in the first place intermittent
measurements people go out of the field
people make observations citizen science
is an important emerging factor here
right there's a lot of debate about
whether or not you can use citizen
science but on the other hand groups
like the national phenology Network who
go out and actually watch for bud break
may be the only way you get coverage
okay the distinction that I'm going to
draw through this talk is I'm not
talking about metadata i'm not talking
about units i'm not talking about what
instrument you do that's different we
handle that differently but it's not as
critical to the science people are
trying to do and by the way this stuff
is teeny you've been hearing about
petabytes I'm here to talk to you about
kilobytes eslary data is really
different first of all it's very hard
one okay you don't put out a sensor and
just wait you go out you dig a pit you
go out and you wade into something you
go out you shoot an air rifle grab the
branch and take it back to the lab you
pay for lab fees right or somebody
spends time in the lab the other thing
that happens is very often it's going
from the literature and then gets passed
around it is very small the flood set
collection that we're dealing with right
now is about 30,000 numbers okay so it
fits on an excel spreadsheet but that's
bad idea and I hope by the end of the
talk you're convinced of that ancillary
data is used very differently sometimes
it uses a constant sometimes it
generates a time series sometimes it's
used as a time filter but time since
fire it's really important if your
interests
understanding but the biosphere and
photosynthesis to know that a fire went
through last year or went through a
hundred years ago because that tells you
the age of the tree okay you also see
spatial aggregations and models so you
know it's it's usage pattern as arguably
as diverse as the data the other thing I
want to point out is that it often
requires scientific judgment i'm showing
one of the chinese sites here on the
coast and we've seen land surface
classification for that site as either a
wetland or a grassland and it all
depends on who you ask so what do you
what is creating ancillary data well
you've got to define a reporting
protocol you've got to define what you
want taken how you want it taken how you
want it reported there has to be a
mechanism for submitting it right once
I've been out of the field I dug my pit
I've made my measurements you want me to
transmit that to you in a CSV file or in
a web form or some mechanism other than
you know by the way I have this
measurement there are emerging archives
oakridge is one archive we are now these
days frankly an archive so coming from
the submission into the archive
constantly cleaning okay I spent a lot
of my life working on this project being
kind of the longest and lastly
outputting data products for scientists
to use but you know let's face it that's
a psyche and raw the same picture for
sensor data I could draw the same
picture for remote sensor data so how
hard can this be I mean its 30,000
numbers what could possibly go wrong
well we started into early two thousand
and seven at the litari conference and
the original Latoya collection was
harmonized by two people who had a
ginormous spreadsheet with 76 columns
and four hundred fifty eight rows and
cells were cut and pasted and cut and
pasted and cut and pasted and I want the
first observation I want to make is with
a spreadsheet that big
the odds on you getting the right cell
when you cut and paste at all times
aren't good okay they're just not good
and figuring out that you did something
wrong is even harder okay if this is low
tech problems low tech problem the other
thing that happened was if you kind of
look through this spreadsheet the
columns right there are all latitude and
longitude two of the folks spent about
two months sorting through the site's
trying to figure out where they work
because latitude and longitude gets
reported in two different items it's
very easy to do the plus and minus is
digital you're all laughing going yeah
how hard can it be well then there's the
problem in this particular case of my
particular favorite zoti no it's in
Russia kind of the middle of middle of
kind of Russia there and we now know
today that there are five sites and they
are located in a cluster he took us
about Deb how long was it nine months to
finally get mail from one of the
investors who says I've been there there
are five sites here's where they are
ping ping ping ping right this site shut
down here this site shut down there but
it took us a while to find the guy and
before then some people thought they
were too sometimes we thought they were
three and because they're so close right
there's kind of one is in a bog and one
is in the pine forest right so they have
to first approximation the same lat long
you can no longer use a lot long as as a
singlish so some part of this again is
capturing that knowledge capturing that
piece of mail where the guy says I've
been there I know right don't pay
attention to the website that says
there's four sites there are five okay
when we pulled apart the spreadsheet and
started looking at it one of the big
first learnings was there was a sort of
a reporting protocol I'll give you an
example of the vegetation type which is
coverage now in theory what this should
be because that was the preferred
question to the investigators was an ITP
classification there were there are a
dozen classifications grassland cropland
woody savannah forest deciduous forests
mixed forests you get the idea the first
three examples there are examples of
what we're actually in the spreadsheet
okay the good guy grassland the guy that
really wanted to tell you everything he
could possibly imagine and the guy that
just didn't follow directions same thing
with canopy high canopy height is how
hide the trees are okay you might think
that that's a number well no it's not
really okay so initially when we simply
thought about curating this stuff you
know I thought canopy height it's a
number right I'm golden the first thing
we learned was you absolutely have to
teach to treat all of this as text you
can cast as numbers you can extract his
numbers but you better count on it
always coming in as text another little
observation why don't think it's on this
slide Europeans use commas
oh and yeah here's the other bad thing
about spreadsheets the original
spreadsheet was passed around at this
conference I personally collect
collected for variants how do I know
they were variants well I chewed them
all up and compared them there's no way
looking at a spreadsheet that's that big
to know whether it's a variant out of
that experience we work together with a
collection of scientists to do the
so-called batam reporting protocol
biological ancillary disturbance and
metadata fatim developed after the
experience very much more prescriptive
about what to report for disturbances in
particular but an enumerated control
vocabulary it's a wildfire it's a
harvest it's a insect infestation and
specific qualifiers if it's a wildfire
was it high medium or low date is the
date approximate right and very
carefully work through each one of these
variables it's a lot harder than it
sounds because in fact the science here
again is very dispersed the people that
worked in forests knew what they wanted
to have reported but they didn't
necessarily know what was the right
thing to do for crops Savannah sites are
somewhere in between okay we specified
units we specified to reporting
mechanisms either a spreadsheet or at
fluxx date org we put up a web form and
very carefully on every single solitary
one put a free-form comment because one
of the things we learned about this
community is they love telling you their
story sometimes the comments are
referenced sometimes the comments a long
diatribe sometimes the comments empty
now in the past and in working with a
number of other environmental sciences
we've seen a lot of sort of other ways
of slightly improving that is to say
it's better than a spreadsheet I'm going
to call it the access approach
and what it really is is you are
entering a maze of twisty little tables
because what happens is that the table
structure is driven by the scientists
conception of the data so for example I
kind of made up a little example here
soil composition would have the sand
percentage the rock percentage but the
biomass table would be different right
and then the disturbance capable would
be different and the phonology table
we'd be different and bullet by the way
a soil sample is different than a
biomass sample in terms the metadata and
everything else so the little kind of I
chart up there that little kind of color
thing that's an actual real-life NRCS
data that's your government at work the
little kind of reddish tables or where
the data are okay the yellow tables are
derived that is to say I I real
relatively sure so for example an
average measurement is computed outside
the database but then sequestered inside
the blue seems to be kind of computed in
one way I don't understand you know it's
it's kind of it's all over the map okay
so one of the problems there is that
very rarely when you see one of these do
you have any source provenance you may
know that it came from the United States
GS but where did they get it when did
they get it when was it last changed I
very rarely added what else yeah it
sounds so simple but they it's clearly
one of these things that grows and grows
and grows and before you know it you've
got soup so what do we do well we went
the database guy way we normalized
everything but in order to normalize
everything we basically had to think
about every data value as having some
number parameters and the parameters are
datum type specific right so the
parameters for disturbance are different
from the parameters from biomass are
different from the parameters from a
soil sample we also baked in the notion
of a folder for provenance so we we
surface data releases
again not necessarily rocket science but
brand new to this community being able
to surface the latest release being able
to resurface frankly we're holding some
data that we don't surface now so we can
we we know it's there but we distinctly
don't don't allow access that's proved
to be very very handy right additionally
we did kind of what I think of as poor
man's provenance submit date submit
group that is to say the template the
website where where do we get it and we
keep every template submit email comment
associated with the submission bar
comment associated with the first look
of the data the date we processed
process it because we do process
templates more than once and a retired
eight that's turned out to be one of
those things that we again we didn't
design in but it's one of those things
that have saved saved as many times
knowing when we got knowing that a value
has been corrected is great knowing who
corrected it and when when you get the
mail from one of our fine colleagues
that says you have the wrong number you
must have screwed it up and we respond
well you know actually we got it from
one of your students okay I'll in order
to pull that off there's I this is one
of those things where fire is a real
computer scientist I would use the word
ontology but let's face it i'm not
really kind of this isn't good enough to
be an oncology there's an enormous data
translation table ok so for the various
submission mechanisms of row text the
variable classification and then does it
have parameters if so what so we
basically take every single column in
any spreadsheet have a row in this table
do the conversion right this also means
that we can have multiple user facing
names for the same quantity that's
critical in this field because depending
on whether you're a biologist or a soil
scientist you will use different words
for the same thing okay it took us
forever to work some of this out
anything else oh one of the things
that's actually turned out to be really
handy is we push out the documentation
of the same table and that's saved us
because from time to time I i know i
forget what AG biomass CT is but by by
having it right in the table i can
simply refer to it ok and lastly a very
simple controlled vocabulary that part
of the database honestly i would hope
that as as we get a richer and richer
semantic we would be able to replace
that with sparkle or other
infrastructure so what does the archive
operations look like well the first
thing we do with with any submissions we
shred it we pull it all apart ok 1 cell
1 row the next thing we do is we fold it
using that decode table so I pulled all
the parameters apart we fold them all
back together for those of you who look
at copies of the slides thats a pumpkin
if you have kids trust me it's a great
pattern then when we're all done folding
we clean well actually be clean before
we clean after did I say we clean a lot
and push out a number of data products
we've been pushing out how many
different ones Deb I've lost track and
we group the parameters right I mean you
think about it from a scientist point of
view I just want the disturbances I
don't really care about anything else so
just give me a report with the
disturbances now I really want the
foliage give me that we've also pushed
out a number that really just do the
info mattox who reports what ok for
example the upper kind of it looks like
an eye chart but it's kind of fun what
you're looking at is the first cluster
of sites because just I think it's about
a four page report so this is about a
quarter of the sites and various
variable groupings going across color
coded as to where we got them whether we
got them from the p.i proper or where
they got them from that harmonized
initial set
one of the things you can see is there
certainly are some sites that are a
little bit laggard in terms of getting
any sort of information out they have
lat long they have the classification
for the veg type but that's really all
other sites have been much much more
forthcoming while it is nominally quote
quote part of your responsibilities at
our honor to submit this information
we've seen in the mayor of Lux about a
third of the site's submitting data okay
very hard one very hard to get out of
the investigator another thing that
having everything in a database lets us
do is it lets us do these kind of arch I
charts I do part of my cleaning with a
glass of wine in my hand I simply plot
it up and what you see here is one of
the variables this is a logarithmic plot
so this particular variable should have
a range of no more than an order
magnitude what's going on here is a
units conversion we have some in one
units and some of the other okay being
able to spot this gives us a fast way of
starting it I don't pretend to be a soil
scientist I don't really you know a love
grandma romance what is that but a plot
like this can tell me I have a problem
lastly we were talking about some of the
reports we've been putting out to a per
site report and the specific cross-site
reports the per site report went out to
the national carbon program being able
to view the data set as a whole being
able to view the data set in a data type
agnostic way is just proved to be
unbelievably handy so we were talking
about template submissions 44 the 120
sites of submitted templates if you kind
of look at this the template creation
date that is to say the date that they
put on the spreadsheet before they sent
it to us kind of plots the first time we
process it sometimes the leg is because
they hold on to it for once sometimes
it's because we've been trying to get
into a regular processing cycle so it's
the two things together last processing
date at this point in time we've
processed every temple at at least twice
some of the templates three times
because sometimes it takes three times
for them to get it right it's it's been
it's been kind of interesting one of the
things though you see is this is not
just a you know sort of nice slope but
this is very very bumpy and what's going
on here is specific events right if
you're at our owner and you're sitting
on top of this data this is work to fill
out the template you got to go talk to
this guy and you got to talk to this guy
and you actually have to compute it and
you have to check work where did I leave
that that happens best when someone says
if you send me this I'll use your site
in my paper so the two campaigns that
we've seen the first the NAC pee pee
campaign that was natural carbon program
in order to be in the Indian alisis and
the synthesis analysis you had to submit
some batam data anybody that didn't
submit batam data fell off okay and we
got a wonderful cluster of submissions
the other times that you see bumps
particularly the early bumps some of
these investigators own more than one
site so for example our collaborator Bev
law and Oregon owns five sites we got
five templates all at once ok so what
have we learned well one thing is that
that we thought that this was one
collaboration right one group of
scientists who are sharing data and
working together and frankly we've
noticed that there's a lot of
differences and some of the differences
are country to country some of which are
collaboration to collaboration we love
working with the Canadians there the
templates we get from them are beautiful
the follow-up we get through them is
beautiful i have exactly one guy i know
the coordinates because everybody feeds
it to him and then he feeds it to me
it's beautiful wonderful i love the
canadians they won't share with anybody
that's the data set that we're holding
tight they will share with NAC p but
they won't share with anybody else but
they're very coordinated they never
color out to the lines americans love
coloring outside
the lines right there is something about
Americans where I'm going to just embed
a you know it says don't embed comments
in your Excel spreadsheet they do it
says only send us one they don't know
there's something about it one of our
very very close colleagues has sent us
let's just say it's his own format and
sort of said well here it is and we sort
of said well how would you map this to
the reporting program LG don't know so
yeah it's very very interesting they the
notion is I think and Deb captured it
really well the third bullet is hers
there they're providing data access but
they're not publishing their data and
yet if you want to have a data product
that is useful for someone else you
really do have to publish you have to
think about it that partial
normalization is absolute goodness that
I mean the approach we've taken with the
database has more than paid for itself
building being able to build a data cube
so I can run those informatics very fast
as yes a data cube is really overkill
technology for 30,000 numbers but boy
it's handy to have to go late night
browsing around and Excel a particular
learning that we were surprised at that
they very often think that template is
their repository of numbers they want to
give that same template to us every year
with just updates because it's the only
place they have where their own data is
one place even the fact that we're
cleaning and giving you one bad they
still want to hold on to that original
so we we inevitably have that well so is
that a correction or did you typo kind
of question every time we process a
template we had set up a process where
particularly on the web form any
submission goes through a science
curator not us right but someone who is
knowledgeable in the science what we've
noticed is that very often what we're
getting there is a rubber stamp oh yeah
check
we were surprised we figured that you
know we put a number in front of them
they look at it and they would say yeah
that looks right no that doesn't look
right we're seeing more and more about
yeah I'll ok everything which of course
is defeating the process right we were
looking to the science curator as being
the one that would protect us against
our own Navy take right I can do the
dumb check that says if I have a
submission with sand silt and clay
percentages that I shouldn't have more
than 100 that's that's easy but you know
any particular break break point or
something like that associated with the
site I can't really do any sanity check
about that the above-ground biomass I
can get in the order of magnitude but
not much further so that's been you know
that's been a surprise and yet right the
guys are using this the minute there's a
bad data point they get all upset right
so somehow another there's this notion
that i don't have to really work to
publish my data but i'm going to expect
at any data that i use is perfect and i
find that just amazing with this stuff
they don't that same approach and
thinking is not in the sensors there's a
notion that the sensor could have had
some other problem blah blah blah you
know that it's not the same as a
conceptual barrier there in the
scientists and lastly i think the
campaigns oh boy those are absolutely
the way to go forget about asking people
particularly an American to fill out
templates tell them that you know we're
collecting data specifically for this
analysis and you will be listed oh yeah
I'm right on that one so where we going
well we're working with a lot of other
folks right instead of working with one
group what we're trying to do is make
technology that can be shared and
generalized and reused in a number of
different collaborations so there's two
other collaborations kind of going on
right now one is within national marine
fisheries folks they get volunteers in
sort of citizen science give them an
hour to training I think it is and then
they walk up a creek and they take notes
about the nature of the creek we're
fools pools
and they do fish counts and they take
little grab samples so it's a little bit
higher quality data than citizen data
but not much but absolutely key data for
making the policy decision on seminary
operations in California and that's
fundamental kind of kind of your tax
money at work as well as as futures
secondly we've started engaging with the
national soil carbon folks is kind of a
map of soil carbon in the United States
that's actually produced as a result of
some field data run through a large
model and they're trying to get ready to
do a much better simulation job that
data will also go into na CP into the
model synthesis work and frankly one of
the things that I've been looking at is
that hold the access question I'm ending
up seeing more and more and more and
more everybody little at access is
dangerous okay it's a good news bad news
the good news is the data is at least
out of Excel the bad news is it's an
access and I'm in that twisty passage of
tiny little table so finding a
technology that can simply map so a
scientist could say oh yeah this column
is that variable right rather than
having to have us computer science
involved is a goal and we're there's
some things coming down the pipe there
from what Microsoft Research that look
promising so with that it's kind of all
I have to say
yeah I don't know I stay out of the
field for the most part two I just hear
the results oh it all depends on the
nature of the scientists it's actually
interested okay for this collaboration
the ancillary data really looks like the
following sorts of data let me give you
the list off the top of my head one is
the soil pit data so digging a pit
looking at soil carbon looking at soil
fraction and soil bulk density they do
biomass estimates by you know literally
taking crops or taking some some sample
of foliage before and after usually in
the various layers of the canopy ah
there is foolish carbon foolish nitrogen
so foliage chemicals grab a bunch of
leaves and you run them through
disturbances keeping track of that
there's tree rings that they take so you
can see the accumulated growth ah
there's root biomass stump biomass you
know because if you've had a fire there
aren't any trees you really want to know
what's left okay so it's really all over
the map the have eight people are taking
altogether different data all right
there really classifying streams as they
go looking at where the stream is shaded
or it's not they usually got the hobo
little sampler for for occasional water
temperature so this stuff is just you
know it's all over the map the phonology
folks go out and look at the tree and
record the date you know is it budding
is it leafing is it okay
depends on which group depends on which
group for the for the flux net folks
they're supposed to be taking it the
same location because they're taking the
sensor data to write for the phonology
folks for the habit folks more or less
they do the same but then they then well
but we haven't been over here so maybe
we ought to go right so again it's this
is not according to the scientific
method any other questions well thanks
for sticking it out very much